after days of being trapped in the
Himalayan mountains in Nepal these
foreign trekkers and local guides have
made it back to the capital since the
nationwide lockdown was brought in to
contain the coronavirus many had been
waiting to return to safety there was a
lot of anxiety but there was also a lot
of confusion we didn't know what was
going on thousands of tourists from
Europe Australia South Korea the US and
Canada have been stuck in trekking
routes across the country Nepal's
Tourism Board says rescue operations are
under way more flights are yet to come
as per our information and till now ten
flights we have landed here in Kathmandu
and under two packs people from
different nationalities there the German
and French embassies have been working
with Nepalese authorities to repatriate
hundreds of their citizens using
chartered planes so with this doctrine
the pandemic is coming to Nepal whether
you like it or not Germany has much
better health care system than a pool so
I think the risk in Germany is much
smaller than here a lot of French people
thought about staying in Nepal because
the situation was better but now we are
also thinking about our jobs and want to
be closer to our families at this time
but some travelers from the UK and US
are still waiting for information on
what will happen next their ambassadors
say they are working on solutions
there will be flights coming into
Kathmandu to go back to London and to
take you home those flights will not be
free they will come in on a commercial
basis but we are working very hard with
the airlines to try to make sure that
the prices are not inflated so many
Americans are in fact outside of
Kathmandu and currently under lockdown
it strikes me that the thing that makes
Nepal such an attractive destination the
ability to get far off the beaten path
is also complicating our logistical work
right
we are currently bringing American
citizens in to Kathmandu from all over
Nepal tens of thousands of visitors come
here every spring for trekking and
mountaineering but now expeditions
businesses and major markets have closed
transport has come to a standstill and
the Nepalese government has extended a
nationwide lockdown but many foreigners
stranded here say they just want to go
home
Rahila muhammad al jazeera